now when you make these changes and look
at the results in dev tools you should
see that the box sizes are different but
there's not actually any change to the
layout of the page first let's take a
look at our my app page before we make
the change notice that the image is 595
pixels wide while the description is
also 595 pixels wide it's basically the
length of our current screen then when
we add our CSS style save and refresh
note that our image is now 460 pixels
which is how we defined it then when we
make our changes and refresh the page
notice that the image is now maxing out
at 460 pixels and when we resize the
screen our description then maxes out at
705 pixels the layout however has
remained unchanged and it's still not
looking like our design Mach